[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex mullering and I am
excited to be walking through this uh
this episode with you so today uh I
wasn't really sure what to do it's kind
of the holiday season so I was thinking
maybe I do something fun and uh holiday
themed but really what I want to talk
about is tournaments so uh we just at
the chess club here had our end of year
staff tournament we get all the staff
who want to to come in and play some
games and uh this was actually the first
year I got to participate so I was
really excited about it and I actually
performed well I was happy with my
performance so I wanted to share my
games with you all and as I'm going
through them I want to talk about not
only how to do some game analysis how to
understand some of the different ideas
we'll be looking at but also just some
general tips for tournaments you know
what to expect how to deal with the
pressure so so let's Jump Right In my
first game was against a guy named
Richard he's in our Scholastics
department so he helps run kind of
events with schools and he is a stronger
player than I realized so when I saw
that I was against him first round I was
like oh I know Richard this will be a
fun game and then I saw his rating 1707
and I thought oh boy I'm only like a
1500 so this will be tough but let's
take a look at the game we sit down and
I was trying as I said I did see his
writing but I wasn't trying to get too
much into my head I do think there is a
psychological element you know you can
already start to be losing ahead of time
and
I decided okay I know he's a higher
rated player but I'm not going to let
that get to me and I decided to just go
in for a fight I wasn't going to try and
play solid I was just going to play so
as best as I could
and he opened with the English opening I
had the black pieces
um and I have recently been kind of
working on my own preparation in the
opening and the English is something
that I for a long time just didn't
really know what to do against I kind of
just played with the opening principles
so I try to control the center for
squares I try to develop my pieces get
my king safe but I didn't really have a
good game plan
um until recently and the move I played
so I played E5 striking in the center he
played Pawn to G3 and there's kind of
two ways that I expect just him to play
either G3 or Knight C3 both of these are
very common moves and he plays G3 so
setting up the bishop not yet committing
his Knight to C3 although it's usual
that it will go there eventually
I played Knight to F6 Bishop to G2 kind
of the whole point of this move
giving him a very nice long diagonal
when a bishop is in the structure we
call it a fiancheted bishop
and uh often this is going to be a very
safe way to Castle
because you have the pawns are doing a
really good job of controlling these
dark squares and the bishop that is in
that Gap covers the light squares
and here my new game plan is
I decided to play the move Pawn to C6
which is uh it has a name that's opening
I forget what it's called
um but the basic idea is very simple is
I'm saying okay by playing C4 you have
controlled the D5 square and are causing
me a problem right I can't just put a
pawn there without trading it for the
center Planet so now that I've played C6
I'm doing really two things one of the
main thing is I am adding more support
to this Square because I would like to
play D5 and trade and just have nice
Center pawns I would feel really good in
this position practically speaking
there is a kind of side benefit which is
while I'm opening up this diagonal for
my queen sometimes it will become
relevant for her to develop to really
any of these squares
um so I'm just keeping that as a
possibility as well there is one big
downside here and actually uh anyone who
plays C3 against the Sicilian Defense
there is a lot of really similar
positions um and that's kind of why I
picked this opening that's what I play
as white and this ends up being
basically a C3 Sicilian just down a
tempo the Sicilian Defense is when you
have the white pieces oops white plays
one E4 black plays C5 and then the C3
Sicilian is obviously then playing C3
and you see the queen comes out you're
defending D4 so a lot of the same ideas
are present it's just now that I'm doing
it with the black pieces I'm down one
tempo white is up a turn because they
get the first move so I do have to the
position's not quite as good as it would
have been
the downside of this C uh three move the
main one in my eyes is it actually takes
away the Square from our Knight normally
you want your Knights to move towards
the center sometimes you will see them
move you know to the edge that's pretty
rare but it does happen more often than
that you'll see them move into the
center but just like up a little bit but
generally speaking you want them as
close to the center as possible Right
controlling as many Center squares here
as you can so the fact that my Pawn is
on C6 means my Knight's not going to get
there as easy so that's kind of a
downside and actually Richard
immediately takes advantage of this he
plays a very good move probably I think
the the most critical move in this
position Pawn to D4
immediately striking in the center not
giving me any time to push my Pawn
because he's attacking me on E5
and also I can't you know just bring my
knight up to defend
so I take the pawn he takes back with
the queen and similarly while I couldn't
bring mine out of defend I also can't
bring it up to attack right so my knight
cannot Pastor his Queen even though it's
in the center it's
and normally you don't want to get your
queen out too early because though she
is very strong and can do a lot she's
also a huge Target and can you know you
you'll have to move her around a lot to
stop her from being taken by a weaker
piece but in this case it's not as big
of an issue
because my knight can't do it uh and in
the chat not in the binary suggesting D5
this is the move I played so although I
can't pester the queen I can uh bring my
Pawn forward so I do I play D5 the whole
plan and we'll talk about plans more in
the second game but planning is an
incredibly important part of your chess
even if you don't have like a very long
term plan just setting up little plans
like this saying I want to play C6
because I want to have two Center pawns
can be really a good idea and following
through with that
okay my opponent plays Knight C3
attacking my Pawn on D5
and here I play a really kind of risky
move I would say this is a bit of a
gamble on my part and I said early on I
wasn't going to just say I'm going to
try and play safe and assume the best
for my opponent because he's higher
rated than me I'm gonna play what I
think are the best moves even if it
leaves me in some tough binds sometimes
and here I thought okay I've seen some
of these positions similar ones when I'm
playing as white in the C3 Sicilian and
the line I know there is to take this
pawn and allow Queen takes d8
because even though my King has lost the
ability to Castle I do have an extra
Pawn it's a doubled Pawn
but it is still an extra pawn and if I
can hang on to it into an end game if I
can keep my king alive and safe in the
center then I actually feel pretty good
my opponent's going to try and
everything they can now to abuse the
fact that my king is a bit stuck and
this is the game it turns into a very
sharp positional battle
uh and my opponent says okay you have a
king on the D file I would love to gain
some extra Tempo by bringing a rook over
with check or maybe even better
queenside castling with check but my
Bishop's in the way so how can I do that
well let's find a good home for this
bishop and you could just bring it up
one or two uh maybe even three Bishop F4
looks like a very reasonable move
controlling this diagonal my opponent
decided to play Bishop to G5
which is pinning my knight to my king
and immediately there are threats right
I have to be very careful to not let my
pieces get overwhelmed
um
maybe my opponent can play a move like
Knight to E4 and threaten to double my
pawns and then maybe I have two sets of
double Pawns
on I mean that's immediately the threat
as you can just take and double my pawns
so even though I maybe I have an extra
one if my pawns are all just that weak
unable to defend each other one of the
big problems with double pawns other
than they just bump into each other
they're in the way is it's also harder
to defend them often because if you're
if I'm using this Pawn say to defend
both of these I have to kind of pick
which one it's defending
if my opponent takes my knight here if I
just do nothing then when I take back
these will be isolated pawns so let's
just say I play some silly move and
allow this to happen
these are even harder to defend because
no other pawns can keep them safe so all
of these things are in my head I'm a
little worried about it and I decide uh
to play
the move Knight to D7
so that if you take my knight I will
recapture I could have played Bishop E7
but I decided I wanted to have a knight
recapture on this square if possible and
I knew my knight wanted to go somewhere
because it couldn't go to C6
maybe the one downside here with this
Knight to D7 move is I am kind of
walking into my opponent's plan my
opponent wants to Castle and put a rook
on this file to attack my king
and so after I do this now I'm pinned in
two areas both of my Knights are stuck
which is not ideal
um
it also makes it a little harder for me
to develop this bishop into the game
right if I had played my Bishop out
earlier maybe my opponent doubles my
pawns but at least my pieces are a
little more active so these were the
trade-offs I was making
um okay so now my opponent is again
threatening to double my pawns because I
will not be able to recapture with my
knight it is pinned my opponent's also
threatening to continue to put pressure
on my pinned pieces with his so I play
Bishop to E7 unpinning
my opponent plays Knight F3
and I decide okay I want to resolve uh
whatever's going on here so really quick
let's go back a second
because someone in the chat has an
interesting suggestion of playing B5 I
really like this idea of B5 or B6 and
maybe pushing onto the queen side I
think I like B5 a little more
um because B5 leaves B6 open for my
night one day
um and also is threatening to push
forward into my opponent's Castle I have
a nice Pawn already on C4 so if I can
use that to my advantage that'd be great
the one issue with this move is my
opponent's Bishop on this nice long
diagonal right if I play B5 at some
point too early then I'm going to get
into a lot of trouble
because my opponent's Bishop just has so
much scope
so I can't just undefend the C6 Pawn but
that is a good thing we want to watch
out for if we have an opportunity to
start expanding on the queen side I
think it's a good idea
uh but in the meantime I need to stop
this threat so I played Bishop E7
my opponent develops with Knight to F3
and I could go for this B5 idea now but
then I have to worry about discoveries
because if this Knight moves then it's
going to be making a threat against me
as well as the bishop behind it which is
revealed we call that a discovered
attack
the the attack has been discovered in
the position it was not there before
because this piece moved out of the way
so I I still want to do this but it's a
little too early in my view I I'm not
quite prepared
so instead I just want to resolve
whatever's happening with this bishop I
wanted to decide if it's going to take
my knight and let me kind of open up
some space or if it's going to back off
and I play the move H6
my opponent drops back to F4
um that he can't stay on this diagonal
that would not work because then I can
play Pawn to G5 and his Bishop would be
trapped
so he drops back to F4
and a few different ideas came to mind
here but I decided to try and get out of
all of these pins I want my pieces to be
active this bishop can't get in the game
as long as my knight can't move my
knight can't move as long as my king
stuck as long as The Bishop's not in the
game My Rooks can't do anything so I
need to start resolving some of these
issues that I willingly decided to go
into I said I'm going to take this extra
pawn and if he decides to trade queens
and hurt my king I have to accept this
as a possibility so I play King to E8
stepping out of this pin and trying to
give myself a little bit of time to
mobilize
my opponent now plays the move on Knight
to D4
and I think he's setting up some
potential issues the main one in my mind
was Knight to F5 which looks to hit my
bishop and hit this Pawn with check
um
and also re it reopens the scope of this
light squared Bishop so I'm keeping a
lot of these threats in mind and I
decide instead of first dealing with
this because I don't really have a great
place to put my knight I could put it on
B6 but I want to wait and still play B5
I can't do that yet because again we
talked about the issues here on C6
um so I decide to wait and I played Pawn
to G5 first trying to create some space
uh Rook he1 yeah he could have played
Rook he1 I think that would have been
fine getting his other rook in the game
maybe preparing to push this Pawn that
also looks uh fine in that position but
he went for Knight to D4 which I
actually think is also very good and
there is a threat here that we are going
to talk about because I didn't see it so
I played G5 and he saves his Bishop he
actually I expected him to retreat but
he actually advances into my territory
and takes up a lot of annoying space
um and I I decided okay I need to find a
way to challenge this bishop I can't let
it last
the plan I made to do that was I was
going to play first think about your
forcing moves right any move
um
that forces your opponent into a limited
number of responses is something you can
always be looking out for because it's
going to help you calculate
so checks captures you know all those
kinds of things
and in this position I saw a threat I
saw I can challenge his Bishop by
bringing mine over to B6
if I go to C5 first I actually attack
his Knight and he has to move it the
downside here is it kind of gives him
this F5 move right he wants to go here
anyway
so maybe it's I think it's a fine move
in general but there is a very specific
problem
because after Bishop C5 I missed
something so if you want to try and take
a guess in the chat at what White's best
move here is see if you can figure out
what white should do here to kind of
capitalize on my position
there's a very strong tactical idea if
you're watching this live feel free to
comment in the video here if you're
watching this later on YouTube or
something
um please feel free to pause the video
at any point and try and guess the move
so you have time
uh okay Teo from the chat here with a
really nice idea Knight takes C6 a kind
of sacrifice if you will this is a very
strong move and I actually saw it in the
game because there is a problem I saw
okay wait if Knight takes C6 if I take
back with my Pawn
then Bishop takes C6
let's take a look at that Knight takes
C6 Pawn takes Bishop takes and my Rook
is totally stuck in the corner here on
A8 because white has planted a bishop on
C7 I actually have nowhere safe to put
my rook and I'm going to lose it and
white is going to get up in material uh
most likely
so yeah this is no bueno I also can't uh
just play like Rook to B8 and trade with
the Knight because this bishop is also
now pinning my knight so my opponent has
basically fully infiltrated my position
probably is going to win material and
also is just getting a lot of positional
pressure so this is a big problem for me
I I looked at this and I actually
thought maybe I'm okay because maybe if
you play Knight takes C6 I might be able
to survive my plan was actually to play
Bishop takes F2 and not take back
because then you're not getting my Rook
the problem with this idea is even
though I get a pawn back White's
development is just much quicker so
perhaps something like Rook to attack my
Bishop I can call check if I want
um but White's pieces are just very
active
my pieces are still much more passive
except maybe this bishop but I think
White's two Rooks this beautiful Bishop
on this diagonal the knight in my
territory I I'm just fairly concerned
about trying to survive this position
so my opponent uh luckily for me missed
that move
and played Knight F5 which is still a
strong move it's just not quite the same
tactical knockout
and I played Bishop to B6 right my
original plan trying to challenge this
bishop
get it to stop taking up my spaces
okay this didn't quite work because he
just pulled back to D6
and again my king is feeling a little
bit locked up
so I'm nervous about potential Checkmate
threats but I'm also seeing that I'm
still fighting back I still have this
extra pawn and if I can just get my
pieces active I'll be okay
so I say what are the current threats
well now that this bishop is kind of
locking my movement on the f file uh and
I can't just escape with my king I don't
really want to allow this check that
seemed a little dangerous it's going to
force me back to the D file where this
Rook is waiting to uh just actively hunt
my king
so I decided to play Rook to H7 to
defend against Knight G7
I couldn't play Rook G8 because then I
hang this Pawn it's not defended anymore
so I play Rook H7 instead
my opponent plays F4 trying to just
break things open on the king side and
one general idea is when your opponent's
king is stuck in the center even if
Queens are off the board though with
Queens on it's more effective because
they're great at attacking if you can
just break open the center
and like get a lot of your pieces lined
up then you're going to be doing quite
well
so F4 is a very sensible move
here I played Knight to C5
looking to finally open up space for my
Bishop I make a discovered attack on my
opponent's Knight so if he doesn't move
it or defend it then I can just take it
and also looking to you know improve my
Knight's Vision I was very happy if my
opponent wants to trade these pieces
that's fine in my book
but my opponent here unfortunately made
a blunder we were playing with 30
minutes game 30 no delay no increment or
anything and my opponent
I think we were both down to like around
five minutes so we'd been sitting here
for a long time really thinking these
moves it was a stressful kind of
positional battle in my opponent played
a very natural looking move Pawn to E4
looking to push forward and uh again the
same ideas right open up my king get
control in the center with his pieces so
active it's very very scary but
unfortunately I have a kind of there's a
problem with E4 so if you want to again
take a minute and see if you can find
the best move for black in this position
what is wrong with the move E4 what his
white left vulnerable for us
okay so uh not in the binary again naive
or sorry Knight D3
okay never mind
that's okay
take some time see if you can find the
right idea this move E4 does do a few
things right it does uh gain space it's
looking to maybe push forward it's uh
defending this Knight so I can't I mean
I can take it and double the pawns so
that's at least a possibility
if I do that though I will open up again
this monstrous Bishop so I want to
always be careful of that
my advice to you in this position is to
look for your forcing moves again
anytime you can play a move that really
limits what your opponent's options are
it's helpful with the calculation and uh
can you know you can usually find
whether your idea works or not very
quickly
so checks captures major threats like
threatening to win a piece for example
okay back to the idea not in the binary
you are confirming Knight D3 check you
like that move I like it as well and the
idea is we're going to force our
opponent to respond after Knight to D3
if they take it with the Rook then I'm
very happy I just want an exchange for
no reason okay so after Knight to D3
probably my opponent will move their
King
and the problem is yeah a soothing
Melody has pointed out wherever this
King moves I now have Knight to F2
forking White's two Rooks
so you always want to look out
especially for like uh there's some very
common positions where pieces will be
oriented in a way that you know if you
have a knight you can Fork them or if
you have a bishop you can Fork them so
always keep an eye out for those is
really helpful and I saw okay I have a
forcing move check after the king moves
Knight to
here to F2 and I'm winning a rook for a
night so I'm winning an exchange
I've won a pawn in the beginning a
doubled Pawn but still and now I've
managed to win an exchange
I feel a lot better now
Rook to D to F1 I take he takes back and
now I'm thinking okay I'm up some
material let's just finally you know
activate some of my pieces this bishop
that's been sitting here the whole game
I will gladly trade it off for White's
pesky night
even though I'm opening up the bishop
now that some more material is off the
board I'm very very happy to be making
exchanges
here I play Rook to d8 trying to
activate this final piece with a little
bit of a sneaky Swindle plan
my opponent uh plays a very natural
looking move so I'm threatening to win
this bishop
he plays Rook to E1 check and I move my
king
and he plays a move that looks
incredibly strong there's just one
problem
he plays the move Bishop to E7
which looks very good it attacks my rook
and my knight
and my Knight's not defended and I can't
defend it with this Rook so it looks
like he's going to win back a piece and
actually now White's going to be doing
better
unfortunately I was prepared for this
and I play Rook to E8 pinning the bishop
to The Rook
and there's really nothing to do here if
you take my knight I will take your Rook
with not just for free but with check so
I can then get another follow-up move so
I'll win another Exchange
and if you don't take my knight if you
play check or if you
you know do any other move I'm just
going to take this bishop with one of my
pieces and just get another full piece
so in this position with not a lot of
time on either of our clocks but enough
time that uh my opponent knew I was able
to win this game uh Richard resigned a
very very strong game I was kind of my
heart was beating the palpitations were
you know very visible new I think we
were maybe the last game to finish there
might have been one other one but a very
stressful game but I was very proud of
myself for having the kind of mental
fortitude to have a plan I kind of got
through the opening with this idea I
said I'm willing to get some extra
material here and go into a little bit
more uncomfortable position and feel
comfortable fighting it out not just
letting my opponent have an easy opening
and it worked out in my favor again he
could have found some nice tactics that
Knight takes C6 Bishop takes uh trapping
my Rook was very strong
um so it was definitely a back and forth
game but uh I'm happy with how I played
now let's look at the uh next game the
next game was not quite as in my favor
although I will say uh I I there's
something about playing an opponent who
is much much stronger than you that can
let you breathe a little easier so in my
perspective I'm playing Richard a 1700
round one I feel like I have a chance
right it's going to be tough but if I
play well I might be able to win and
that's what happened
round two I was playing the chess clubs
one and only Caleb Denby National Master
very very strong and actually the
highest rated player in the tournament
and I
there's I think a very important
distinction here I don't think you
should go into a game you know expecting
to lose or playing for a draw
um because usually psychologically
that's going to cause more harm than
good in your play but I could breathe a
silent relief you know saying I don't
have to beat myself up if I miss a move
or if I play a bad move because Kayla's
a very strong player which means I can
just play really strong chess as good as
I can and see what happens
um this game is a little bit more
complicated I mean the first one was
certainly complicated but
um I seeing as I lost this game I might
not be able to explain all the ideas
fully but I'm gonna do my best
I had the black pieces again here and
Caleb started with Pawn to D4 and I go
into a kind of King's Indian style setup
Knight F6 C4 G6 and I was expecting here
the very normal lines I know Caleb has
done lots of lecture series on the
king's Indian please feel free to check
those out very high quality content and
I from my understanding he often plays
the main lines right Knight to C3 Pawn
to E4 Bishop E2 castles he's going to do
all the normal stuff
and in this game he actually played Pawn
to H4 which is something that I'd only
seen once before that I could recall and
it was actually playing another master I
played this against uh our former
Grandmaster in Residence uh Alexander
shabalov
and he also uh he also beat me in this
um but I I had learned a little bit
since that game and wanted to try out
something different and it didn't
exactly work but let's talk about why
because the the key word I have for this
game is plan
and in this game
uh well actually let me start with this
in the game I played against chabalov
my immediate move I believe I might have
played like a few more normal moves but
eventually very quickly I played the
move Pawn to H5
very simply saying I'm a little nervous
that you were going to push this Pawn
farther into my camp and I would like to
at least have some safety here on the
king side
it's a word of worked against uh
I don't believe he destroyed me on the
king side I think he just kind of
destroyed me in general
um but against Caleb I wanted to try
something different my first game I said
I'm not just gonna you know give my
opponent an easy opening or Play Moves
because I'm afraid I'm gonna play what I
think are the best moves and so I played
normal chess I played D6 Knight C3
Bishop G7
E4
and here I thought I should Castle uh
but I I was a little afraid of Pawn to
H5
so instead
um I played Knight to A6 and this is a
move that I really like in the king's
Indian defense although I wasn't really
sure how it would square up against this
early H4 idea
my idea here is actually to play Pawn to
E5
and kind of fight for control of this C5
square and this B4 Square
so we'll kind of see that happening
um kind of maybe some other more normal
looking moves maybe Knight C6 and you
might see something like this but I was
a little afraid of getting Pawn stormed
so I held off on that
and again castling I think is fine but
I'm also a little afraid of getting the
H Pawn too much pushed forward
um so I played this Knight A6 move
and my opponent played Knight G to E2
which is another move that I was not
expecting at all and this actually cost
me quite a lot in this game because
something very important is when you are
making a plan in chess you need to be
reactive to your opponent so I think
it's important to both be proactive in
your chess and right try and set up
plans for you to do but also be aware of
what your opponent's doing so being
reactive you need to have a balance if
you're all one or the other you're not
going to be playing very well
the problem with this move for me is
that it's really going to flummox one of
my major plans and one of those for
those less familiar with the king's
Indian defense one of the major ideas is
you want to usually strike out on the
king side so moves like F4 or sorry F5
F4 are very very common
unfortunately these two moves in
particular really make that kingside
plan less good because White's plan is
eventually to put this Knight over on G3
and really have a lot of control and try
to lock down this F5 move and we're
actually going to see that play out
so here I played Pawn to E5 my plan my
opponent plays D5 which gives me the C5
square and I'm feeling very happy here
Knight to G3 like we said controlling F5
and I play Pawn to A5
and my plan is now I would like to
advance this pawn and create some
weaknesses in my opponent's Pawn
structure I'm not sure what he's going
to do but between my knight and my Pawn
I feel like this is going to be very
strong
my opponent plays Pawn to H5
and now I've realized okay this is
despite being me and the King's Indian
I'm fighting him on the queen side he's
fighting me on the king side this is not
normally how things go but let's just
see what happens I play Pawn to A4
and he plays Bishop to E3 trying to
undermine my knight right because this
Pawn is only defended by my knight in my
Rook if he can get rid of my knight then
perhaps this Pawn Falls
now I may be overvalued how important it
is to control this Pawn because even if
he ends up taking it maybe I still have
some nice pressure on this open file
um but I instead played Knight 2 D7 and
this is maybe the first kind of sign
that I'm not doing exactly what I'm
supposed to be
after the game Caleb kind of mentioned
this move he wasn't so sure about it
because he said just retreating might
have been a little too slow
my plan right that we talked about is I
would like to play F5 but again look at
how my opponent has set up with his
Knight on G3 his Pawn here very easily
he can bring his Bishop out to defend
it's really difficult for me to get away
with F5 furthermore as long as my knight
here is on D7 my Bishop which is a key
defender of the square is actually now
cut off from it
so in retrospect maybe this isn't the
best move
a better one could have been Pawn to C6
which is normally a move I would not
like to play because I'm afraid of
making a backwards Pawn
often in these types of positions what I
would expect is for my opponent to trade
and for this Pawn to become kind of a
weakness that because I don't have a
pawn that's capable of Defending it
it's going to be a big Target maybe my
opponent really puts a lot of pressure
on this Pawn somehow
what I didn't realize is actually I'm
probably going to have enough time to
push my Pawn to D5 and redefend it
before that becomes an issue but I
didn't see that far ahead
so instead I played Knight back to D7
Bishop E2 and here another kind of
mistake I made I played Pawn to A3
uh Caleb after the game also said that
maybe it would have been better for me
to have delayed this move
um kept it in reserve to gain some Tempo
at a key moment and try and you know
cause issues for white depending on how
he played but because I kind of show my
hand too early
he can just easily sidestep me
and this again shows what my plan is
right my plan was to weaken some of
these the spawn structure over here
because I would like to play F5 and open
up right push forward with these two
pawns and open up this beautiful dark
Square Bishop
this is normally a very good plan
it's just a little too slow because of
the way my opponent is playing against
me right he's responding to what I'm
doing and being proactive and making
plans and I'm kind of just tunnel
visioning here's what I want to do and
I'm going to try and force my way
through it
that actually continues with the very
next move right the next move I play is
okay I'm thinking I need to continue
this plan so what do I do I don't want
to you know move this Knight back or
move it out of the way it needs to keep
defending this but I don't have another
good way to defend my Pawn right my
Bishop is stuck so I make kind of a
convoluted plan I say I'm going to play
My Queen over push this Pawn up a little
bit and slowly but surely work my pieces
in formation to push it forward
and this is okay the planning is good in
general it's just it's just too slow
so I play Queen E7 my opponent plays
Bishop to G4
and here I really should have just said
okay I've put a lot of pieces in play I
really need to just commit to this plan
and play F5
if I play F5 okay probably I'm going to
lose a pawn but maybe I can try and push
some compensation I think white is still
doing better here
um probably significantly better but
this is also probably the best I'm gonna
get because I've set up all my pieces to
try and have this nice open diagonal and
I can get it
it's just maybe a little too slow and
not worth the cost the way I do it so I
play F6 he plays King to D2 normally and
you can see neither of us have castled
that's because this is a very closed
position
all of these pawns are kind of locked up
there's not really any trades available
at the moment so it's okay for the Kings
to have stayed in the center it's harder
to attack them and also the Rooks are
doing very important jobs right
especially his Rook over here he would
like to keep putting pressure on the H
file my Rook I would like to keep
putting pressure here and neither of us
wants to Castle into this Zone where our
opponent has attacked
so he's staying in the center
Queen to F7 again this plan of very
slowly working for F5
Queen to F3
uh Knight B6
finally I say okay if you want to take
my knight you can take it but I need to
do something I need to open up some
attacks and try and get F5 through
he plays H takes G6 H takes Rook takes
h8 check Bishop takes some very forcing
sequences and then Rook H1 attacking my
bishop and here I play a forcing
Intermezzo so I'm playing an in-between
move instead of Defending my Bishop I
play Bishop takes G4 because now if he
takes me then I'm just going to move my
king even though he takes me with check
I move my king and now both my Rook is
attacking his so he needs to defend his
Rook but he also needs to defend his
Queen
so he doesn't want to you know invite
those issues right if he takes either
step out of the way and he can't solve
both problems
so instead he takes my Bishop first and
then I move my king anyway to now defend
my own Bishop
Bishop takes C5 so he does decide to
take here and I'm thinking okay fair
enough
Rook H6 putting pressure on my G6 Pawn
so I defend it with Rook to G8
and Knight to B5 and I actually
anticipated this move uh for some time
and I had a plan to deal with it I
thought okay you're attacking my Pawn
here you're defending D6 but I'm
actually okay I pushed C6 because now
I'm thinking
if you push then I think I can maybe
just defend I I my knight is controlling
some really crucial squares my queen and
Rook might be able to help me out I
think I might be able to survive
and if you take
then now you've opened up the D file so
maybe I can get some counter play
against your king
uh hello Roland Titan welcome to the
episode uh so he does play D6 I move my
king and I'm thinking I'm probably fine
now my opponent is a national master and
I looked at the computer after this game
and he actually only has one move to
retain any advantage and he finds the
best move the move I was expecting I was
expecting him to play Knight takes A3
and then I would play Knight to C8 take
this pawn and try and open up an attack
in the center and I felt okay maybe
White's doing better but I still have
something to fight for
instead he plays Knight to C7
and I thought at first maybe this is too
ambitious I I think I can survive but it
turns out he was correct
I play Knight C8 attacking his Pawn
he calls check I move out of the way
and he plays a move that I had missed a
very very strong move Queen to H3
lining up his Queen and Rook against my
bishop and because his Knight is now on
E6 he actually cuts off any squares I
can move to defend my Bishop
right my queen cannot go to either of
these squares it will be taken by the
Knight
and if I move my Bishop up here
then he can very simply play Rook to H7
pinning the bishop it's attacked by the
Knight
and this feels pretty uncomfortable
so I recognized okay I'm probably going
to lose that piece he saw something I
didn't see I I was also fairly low on
time at this point and decided I'm gonna
go for a gamble I played Knight takes D6
Rook takes h8
with my idea that I would now like to
move my king out of the way see if he'll
trade Rooks or not
um
and then maybe I can try and get some
counter Play by taking on this Pawn
opening some stuff up probably he wins
but maybe I can threaten Perpetual check
this was my big plan at this point I
probably should have taken the rook and
tried to enact this plan in some way
and white is still fine white actually
has a checkmating attack if they are
able to play carefully and precisely and
spot it but
um it's probably about as good a chance
as I would have at that point in the
game instead I played King to E7
hoping to avoid trading Rooks and my
opponent played one more move and I
resigned
in this position my opponent played the
move Rook to H7 pinning my Queen to my
king
I cannot block with the Rook because
again the Knight covers that square and
I recognized in my mistake and I
resigned uh I was very I was still very
happy with this game but I think the
most destructive thing for me about it
was thinking about plans right
transforming from an opening to a middle
game to even a kind of End Game Plan
um but especially opening into middle
game where I was very focused on my idea
I wanted to break through first I wanted
to kind of uh harm his Queen side so
that it would be weaker so that whenever
I opened up on the kind of King side in
the center and opened up my dark squared
Bishop it would be very strong this was
my plan basically from the very
beginning and unfortunately I wasn't
paying very much attention to the moves
my opponent was playing or rather I was
paying attention to them but I wasn't
factoring in how they would actually
affect my plan right I didn't think
about how him eventually pushing H5 and
opening up my king side would make it so
pushing my own pawns there was too
weakening I didn't think about how his
Knight going to E2 and then G3
would really put a damper on me playing
F5
so really taking into account the plans
you're making and being both proactive
with them and also reactive is uh the
what I learned from this game and what
I'm trying to impart to all of you
now let's go into the final game round
three
so I've won one lost one and in this
round I'm playing someone who I've
played a few times before he's a 1300
I'm about a 1500 somewhere in the middle
and
um but I've played them before and we
were fairly even
um I I maybe have a slight Edge but my
friend here Nate at the chess club
and so I knew again this is going to be
this is going to be a tough one I can't
just can't just have an easy win here
um I played oh so in this game yeah last
round
and again I'm kind of I've played two
very long games at this point so I'm a
little bit kind of frazzled in my brain
um but thinking if I can just play solid
chess I'll that's all I can do
Pawn to E4 and Nate is very fond of
alkyne's Defense
so Knight to F6 the idea with this move
if you're not very familiar
is basically black is one the obvious
threat they're threatening to take on e4
but they're also sort of inducing light
to make a few different kind of mistakes
maybe white just tries to defend this
but does so in a way that blocks some of
their pieces
um the main move is to play E5 which is
kind of the double edge right it's what
white wants to take more space to get
some Tempo but it's also sort of what
black ones black would like to lure
White's pawns too far forward and then
uh kind of take them all out and gain a
really good control in the center with a
counter attack
so D4 D6 and you can see immediately
black is trying to fight against my
Center
here I played Bishop C4 attacking his
Knight he drops back and I play Bishop
to B3 uh because he was attacking me I
had to move out of the way and if he
wanted he could trade these pawns here
and trade Queens
but notice how if he goes into this
position unlike my game against Richard
where we had a kind of early Queen trade
um and I was up a pawn in this case I'm
not up a pawn but I'm also not really in
danger because black is not nearly
developed enough to cause any long-term
attacks right it's pretty easy for me if
I really need to get my king safe I can
play Knight F3 King E2 slide The Rook
over and my king can hide but I can also
bring a lot of pieces to the defense of
my king very quickly
so I think this is probably fine but
black is also maybe not going to be able
to capitalize on having my pawns being a
little weaker
so instead he plays another very good
move Pawn to A5 and I actually make a
mistake here
I the main move and the move that I kind
of have seen before
um I don't play alakai's defense a lot
so I I was trying to remember but it's
actually to play Pawn to A4 and just
kind of have these two pawns stop each
other and say we're both going to
control space
because I actually really shouldn't let
him push forward I played Pawn to C3
just fortifying my Center giving my
Bishop an escape square with the thought
that if he plays A4 I'll just Retreat
and it's probably fine
but actually this is fairly good for
black if he plays A4 I retreat
now he can trade
and
um
this is a slight Improvement on the
position for black because my Bishop is
a little less active his Pawn has a
little more space and
um yeah this is slightly better but he
decided not to go for this instead he
just plays Knight to C6 developing very
normal and I play Pawn to F4
a little more aggressive but my idea now
is if he tries to take what he does then
I recapture and I maintain this really
beautiful Pawn chain in the center
so I don't have to go into this line
where I'm trading Queens that's off the
table now I'm going to have a beautiful
Pawn chain and I've also opened up the f
file because I'm thinking maybe there's
a potential attack on F7
uh for those who don't know F7 or F2
right these two F pawns at the starting
position of the game
are actually the weakest
uh Pawns in the whole position because
they are defended only by the king all
right every other Pawn is defended by
something else
but the F pawns are only defended by the
King which means if you can attack them
enough you can break through right to
your opponent's king
so this is sort of a kind of secondary
plan I didn't really get to enact it in
this game but my thought was maybe I can
quickly Castle play Queen F3 and I just
have a lot of pressure maybe my knight
goes to G5 and I can get a lot of
pressure against this Pawn
um my opponents kind of stopped those
plans by playing Bishop to F5 and E6
which is a very smart move order if he
plays E6 first to lock my Bishop out
then his Bishop is going to be stuck
here uh not really able to develop so he
very wisely develops his piece first
and then locks it in so now instead of
his Bishop being trapped it's out
controlling space and his King is also
safer from this attack my Bishop is not
as menacing as it was before
eye cattle
Bishop to E7 so he's preparing to Castle
himself and I play a bit of a dubious
move here
um I don't think I calculated that long
in the game but I probably should have
spent a little more time on it
but in the game here I played Bishop to
E3
just developing my piece
um not really sure where to go with it
maybe bishop F4 would have been a little
better
but there is a problem with this move
it's not like a Game ending problem but
I do think I give black the advantage
here so see if you can figure out why
this move is maybe not the best it's not
immediately obvious but my opponent did
find the right idea so what might be the
subtle issue with this move
foreign
and while you're thinking about what
might be the slight problem here kind of
my motivation is I knew I wanted to get
this bishop out somewhere because I
wanted to bring my knight in similar to
before where we had pawns on C3 or you
know C6 I can't plan my knight to the
square it normally would like to go so I
need to get my night out but I will kind
of learn from my first game I don't want
my Bishop stuck underneath the Knight so
I wanted to bring the bishop out first
and then the Knight the problem is
actually as uh
tail has found in the chat
so very nice black has some forcing
moves here to kind of punish this and uh
wagoner88 also found the idea
um this bishop is actually a bit of a
Target
if we can get this Knight to common in
an attack
unfortunately my Bishop is really
controlling all these squares but you
can force my Bishop away with this nice
tempo right this forcing move A4 so my
opponent plays A4 I have to drop the
bishop back and now Knight to C4 and my
opponent's kind of encroaching on my
territory and saying you've wasted a
move actually two because not only did
you bring your Bishop out
now you have to bring it back because
otherwise you're going to lose this Pawn
I guess I could have played Queen to C1
here
and defend everything but I don't really
want to lose the bishop pair so I
brought my Bishop back and I'm thinking
okay you got me that was a little
annoying but I misplayed it slightly
but then my opponent I think misplays
slightly probably the best here would be
just to do something like trade these
Bishops because my opponent might not
want me to double their pawns so uh he
takes twice and then castles I think
this looks quite reasonable
unfortunately he goes a little bit uh
too hard and he plays the move on to A3
which actually kind of flummoxed me at
first I was a little nervous that this
that I might have just fallen into an
opening trap
um because this actually looks quite
dangerous his Knight Rook Bishop all
defending this pawn and now he has
threats of taking and forking my rook
and Bishop so this is actually not so
good
um I do have a way out of this though
there is a problem with this move
because in the same way that my move A3
against Caleb was overextending a little
bit too far this is also the same thing
so I played Pawn to B3
and my opponent here now has a difficult
choice
he can either Retreat his Knight
which then
um lets me just continue to March
forward and take space or he can
continue to invade
excuse me so he plays Knight B2
and I can't take this piece if I take
his Knight then he takes back with the
pawn and notice that my Rook is fully
trapped in this corner
I I actually have no move I can play to
stop him from taking my rook and
promoting to uh probably a queen I mean
sure I'm gonna take it next move I can't
let him keep it but um this is going to
cause me some very serious problems
so I can't take it but he is attacking
my queen and so I thought here okay
what if I just move my queen kind of
casually out of the way
with the idea of it now your Knight's
actually kind of trapped on this square
and I would like to eventually get my
Bishop out of the way perhaps I will
trade perhaps you will and then I will
just take your knight and win a pawn
that looks pretty reasonable to me and
that's actually what happens so probably
he should have taken me just so his
pawns don't get doubled he ended up
castling which allows me to hurt his
Pawn structure slightly
I take on B2
the computer actually says here Knight
takes A3 is the best move which blows my
mind because I'm like wait this piece is
not defended but the computer is just
getting some extra tempos and kind of
opening up space removing a Defender
because it just wants to March these
pawns down the board so that's kind of a
cool little move
um but I did I just played the normal
move to win a pawn
and here I'm thinking okay
I forget how much time had passed again
game 30 I might have spent seven eight
minutes
um he probably spent 11 or 12.
and I'm thinking okay I'm slightly ahead
on time and I'm up a pawn
and I really like my position
um my king is maybe slightly vulnerable
on this diagonal so I have to be a
little careful of that maybe I want to
play King H1 one day and this night I'm
not really sure where it wants to go if
it goes to D2 then it can't really go to
F3 yet and it can't go to E4 because now
my opponent's Pawn controls so maybe it
goes to C4 I wasn't really sure what to
do with this Knight
um but I do have a really beautiful Pawn
chain and I'm happy to just kind of
continue to put pressure in the center
and maybe slowly push forward
my opponent plays to move Knight A5
which I think is kind of interesting and
I actually missed his idea I thought
this was a little silly maybe his Knight
shouldn't be on the edge but he's also
controlling some potentially relevant
squares in this type of position I
wouldn't want to play a move like B5 or
sorry B4 because even though this
attacks his Knight it actually gives him
really good control of a good Square
he can maybe now play Knight to C4
attack my queen have some threats so I
want to be careful not to just attack it
but I also can't really do anything to
punish him for having this Knight on the
edge normally I would like to try and
take away the squares he can go to so he
can go back to C6
which means I can try and control D5
maybe to then get D6 but I can't do that
right away his Queen will just take me
so I'm not actually sure what to do with
this move I decide just to play Knight
to D2
just to develop my piece and
kind of play it that way
in retrospect what I missed is he was
playing this move for two reasons one
for control of these squares which could
become relevant but mostly because his
Knight was in the way he wanted to break
with C5
he is still playing his original plan in
a varied form but he sees that I have a
very strong Center of Pawns and he needs
to break them up so C5 to try and
disrupt my pawns is his plan
so Knight bd2 and C5
I don't want to take
for two reasons one if I take his Pawn I
actually activate his Bishop he takes
back with check and Black's kind of got
the move
but also
if I take I'm isolating my E Pawn and I
really value that these pawns are
connected
so I don't take i instead play Rook to
D1
and he plays F6 again uh some people
will if you're familiar with Ben
Feingold a friend of the chess club he
says never play F6 and that's generally
true but I don't think there's any ever
rule in chess there's always an
exception perhaps that is the Only Rule
to chess that there is always an
exception to the rule
um
yeah so tail King H1 instead of the
night there is also fine that's
prophylaxis just getting out of
potential danger no harm in that move at
all
would have also been good
um actually the move I probably would
have played looking at it now I probably
would have played Just Rook D1 right
away
to threaten to play D5 right if he plays
C5 now I just push past and now his
Knight is a little silly I have a nice
past Pawn so that would be good but yeah
King H1 also would have been fine
um but he plays F6 and the reason F6 is
maybe a dangerous move in some cases is
because it opens up this weak diagonal
to attack the king in the same way that
when I played F4 I was maybe taking that
same risk but I don't have a good way to
attack this diagonal right my queen
can't do anything I don't have a light
squared Bishop so he's probably fine
um so he again wants to try and break up
my Pawn chain as best as he can
and here I play Knight to C4 I decide
I'm going to add an extra Defender here
and also if he wants to trade this
Knight I'm fine with that I'm happy to
double these pawns temporarily to add
some extra Defenders to D5 and also open
up space for my queen to attack
he doesn't go for that right away he
plays he takes D4 I take back with the
pawn
a question for you though why shouldn't
I take with the Rook because at first I
thought maybe I can take with the Rook I
get an isolated Pawn so that's maybe not
great but I do get some Tempo on the
queen and maybe I just after that will
take this Pawn anyway
and I'm feeling okay but there's a very
specific reason I can't play Rook takes
I have to play Pawn tanks
what would black do if I take their Pawn
on D4 with my Rook
yeah yeah Roland Titan in the chat you
got it Bishop C5 Bad News Bears we have
lost our uh our Rook we're gonna lose
the exchange so always be careful of
pins
um okay
so C takes D4 I have a nice Center
and he just continues to trade F takes
C5 I take with the pawn revealing a
discovered attack on his Queen
and now even though this Pawn is
isolated it is a nice passed Pawn very
well defended kind of moving into enemy
territory so I'm happy with my Pawn on
E5 I'm still only up one Pawn but I'm
happy for it to be this one
uh in this position he has to do
something right I'm attacking his Queen
and he plays kind of a clever move
Knight takes C4
now if I take his Queen he takes mine
but in the end I'm probably gonna lose
this rook and he may or may not lose
this Knight so I don't want to do that
trade I just take back
and again he plays another Intermezzo
Bishop to C5 check hitting my king so I
don't have time to take his Queen I move
King to H1 now
and he plays Queen to E7 defending his
Bishop stepping in front of my Pawn
it is a lot of Pawn Island's rolling so
I wasn't thrilled but because this Pawn
is a past pawn and I think I actually
have it pretty well defended if I need
to I can bring my Rooks over here and
maybe double them up
um I do think this is a worthwhile Pawn
it's not as good as if it was connected
but it is still something
and here I decide to continue to invade
so Rook to D5
defending my Pawn again ready to double
up I would love to play my other Rook 2
D1 and just have a lot of control here
and I'm also making a very specific
thread if you play something like H6 my
plan was to go Queen to B5
where I am hitting his Bishop twice and
I'm also threatening maybe to play Rook
to D5 so this looks quite good to me
instead he plays B6 which kind of
limits that threat because now I'm only
going to be threatening this move his
Bishop will be defended
so I just continue to bring my other
Rook into the game
and here I think is where he starts to
kind of misplay he's getting low on time
and the game ends fairly soon he plays
Rook to A4 attacking my Pawn on C4 which
is an okay idea it's just I think a
little too slow my threats are probably
bigger than his
um he plays all right sorry so here he
does allow me to play Rook D7 so I take
the seventh anytime you can double up
your Rooks or put them on the seventh
rank you're really limiting your
opponent's space taking massive control
so uh and I also have a bit of a trick
he plays Queen to E6
and I play Knight G5
and I I'm not proud of this but in this
moment I did a little bit of a
you know like try and act like maybe
I've missed something and uh you know
there's a bit of a psychological element
to chess he ends up taking my Pawn
thinking that I've missed this pawn and
now the game is basically over
because I have a really problematic move
Pawn to E6
defended by my knight so he can't take
it with his Queen looking to continue to
press forward and you can try and stop
the pawn but I've also opened up another
threat he doesn't see that threat so he
plays Rook takes A2 and I get to play
Queen takes G7 checkmate
my Rook on D7 right getting Rooks on the
seventh is really really valuable
um so that's how that game ended
I hopefully this has kind of been
helpful for you in both thinking about
playing in tournaments in general
um I had a fun time here and I'm happy
to share it with you and I wish you luck
in your chess I think this is the last
time I'll be seeing you before the
holidays so everyone please be safe have
fun I wish you well and I look forward
to seeing you in the new year thank you
for watching and please stick around for
our grand master in Residence to deliver
a stream right afterwards so stay tuned
[Music]
thank you